hey guys i'm ryan wright so i'm gonna
check out a video that i'm really
interested in watching uh someone sent
it to me in the comment box and i was
like i gotta check this out it's an
exclusive video james cameron on
terminator genesis i am very intrigued
on hearing what he has to say
about terminator part five because i
just watched terminator one and two i
showed it to veronica about a week ago
[ __ ] love those movies hands down
terminator 2 was one of my top three
favorite films of all time terminator 3
was
it was fun
kind of sucked and part 4 um i'm trying
to wipe for my memory but i'm interested
in hearing what cameron has to say
the god of the box office
i had no idea what to expect sitting
down i wasn't involved in the making the
film
i didn't direct it i didn't write it i'm
just a fanboy
it's when a dark theater movie starts
the machine sent a terminator back to
the time before the war to kill my
mother sarah connor and i start to see
things i recognize
it's being very respectful of the first
two films nice night for a walk eh your
clothes give them to me now
you sure sink
and then all of a sudden it just swerves
i've been waiting for you
and now i'm going on a journey
i feel like the franchise has been
reinvigorated like this is a renaissance
come with me if you want to live
everything's changed
if you look at why the films became
classics they had characters that you
like that terminator is out there it
can't be bargained with
it can't be reasoned with
and it absolutely will not stop
ever
the new film which in my mind i think of
as the third film we see arnold take the
character even farther
interesting everybody responds to sarah
connor
for women i think she represents a kind
of empowerment
nice try
and yet there's a vulnerability there
because that strength comes out of price
you cannot risk yourself even for me do
you understand you're too important we
went from in the first film the
terminator being the worst badass in
history
yes
two in the second film him being almost
a father figure
the idea of taking john connor and
flipping him to the bad guy
what have they done to my son survive
was what you taught me it's pretty cool
because you gotta riff against
expectations
it's all about the twists i'm not
machine
not man i'm
woo
all right
that is [ __ ] awesome to [ __ ] hear
yeah oh dude i'm jack now [ __ ] james
cameron's seal of approval on the
terminator 5 film and i like how he said
that he kind of considers it he
considers it part three like we're
ignoring part three and four actually
because those aren't that great but
that's really [ __ ] cool to hear that
james cameron likes it and it's
interesting because there are things
that i said i liked about it and the
trailers that james cameron saying has
worked in the film which makes me really
happy because a lot of the things i said
that will work about it a lot of people
were disagreeing with me like how he was
talking about how they take familiar
elements things that look reminiscent of
the first one you're like oh okay i've
seen that before but then they flip it
and i like how they do that mixing up
the time travel kind of messing with the
first one and second one so not ignoring
it but honoring it and it was cool to
hear james cameron be like yeah it
really worked he didn't necessarily
comment on the performance but i was um
game of thrones fans are going to hate
me for not knowing her name right now
but the woman who plays sarah connor and
terminator genesis when i saw the
trailer for it i was like i'm not sure
how she's gonna do in this role it kind
of looked a little over the top so the
way cameron was talking about sarah
connor was awesome because i was like
this woman probably does a really good
job actually like it seems cool to me
that these filmmakers have taken over
the franchise and are actually knowing
what to do with it he was talking about
how because if you look up like a lot of
those top 100 villains of all time
arnold from terminator 1 tends to be in
there and then if you look up top 100
heroes of all time arnold tends to be in
there for terminator part two which is
so cool because they're different
terminators it's arnold playing them and
one goes down and one of his greatest
villains of history one of the greatest
heroes of history in the second one and
he's saying that in this one they take
that character even further now i was
under the impression that arnold was
going to be there but kind of play a
role like how he did in terminator 3
where he was just the terminator doing
the mission they didn't really give him
like character really but it sounds like
they're actually adding layers back to
the terminator that arnold's playing
which gets me really excited but yeah i
know i'm just [ __ ] stoked that james
cameron has given this movie the seal of
approval the john connor twist that
people have been complaining about i at
first didn't mind that it was in the
trailer but when i started hearing other
people talking about it saying how it
really ruins a lot of the film then i
started to agree with it going yeah that
does ruin a lot actually but the way
james cameron was talking about it he
was making it sound like that john
connor is the main villain of this
particular movie he wasn't talking about
as if it was a spoiler or that it was a
big giveaway it sounds like it might be
part of like the first act in a way but
regardless i've been looking forward to
this film i'm waiting for the pre-sale
tickets to go up yeah james cameron
approving this [ __ ] um
[ __ ] dude man the guy's like the king
you know he i i i hear he's a total dick
to work with
kate winslet said she would never work
with him ever again you know but he's
it's very impressive all like so many of
the films he's done like he did titanic
in 99 became the number one grossing
movie of all time first movie to pass a
billion dollars almost made two billion
dollars and then he waits about 10 years
does avatar no movie has surpassed
titanic at this point he does avatar
after 10 years and that surpasses
titanic despite what you might think
about avatar i thought it was okay it's
still impressive what he was able to do
with that film hearing this guy
listening to his track record the
inventor of the terminator series giving
this film a seal of approval makes me
really happy because three and four left
me disappointed anyway guys thanks for
tuning in if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can follow us on facebook instagram
and twitter where if we get enough
followers we can get product placement
for things such as
hold on money
money is great you know people say money
is the root of all evil i think lack of
money is the root of all evil you could
be rich and you could be poor which one
do you think is going to make you feel a
little better come on so yeah i would
like to get product placement um from
people who will provide me with
money i don't want free products i don't
want you to promote me in any way i just
want you to give me money
so i can spend it
on hookers for my girlfriend because she
won't let me sleep with any hookers but
i'd like to watch her do something with
another guy
yeah terminate her you know
i can't say that